new local spot perfect for unique gifts
and food
the international food court inside el
mercado opened earlier this month and
rocky stopped by to check it out
have you been down to el mercado at the
boulevard mall yet this place is
incredible it is full of culture
and fun and food well last time we were
here the food court was not open but now
it is
yes welcome back thank you so before we
get to that just introduce people to el
mercado so el mercado is a collection of
over 100
unique small shops family owned
unoperated and local
and uh with an emphasis on you know
south american
latin gifts unique one-of-a-kind finds
i love it and unique one-of-a-kind foods
yeah i would say
so what can you find at the food court
mariscos los cabos
it's a mexican restaurant with an
emphasis on seafood
great uh food that you see there and
shrimp cocktails
mouths already ceviche stuff like that
all right and then i see arifest cafe
what is that
yes so this is a brazilian venezuelan
and argentinian cuisine uh you get the
empanadas and uh
i'm gonna go with this guy right here
and they've got great uh arepas
uh which is like a little sandwich with
a pock in a pocket
really good stuff that was this is
delicious and then
my favorite churros yep a little bit for
the sweet tooth over here with the
churros
they've got all kinds of churro
creations a lot of it you can see up
there on the screen
uh traditional churros and then really
really good
uh tortas which is like a big mexican
sandwich
i love it and then i love that there's
702 trolls you're combining las vegas
with latin culture
oh yeah 702. thank you all right what do
we have next cuban cafe
yeah we've got wonderful cube and
cuisine so
you guys do you guys have platinos oh
yes that is my favorite definitely one
of my favorites as well
i'll be back for it's a go box
this is super unique i love that this is
cajun mexican food yep
cajun mexican food um so shrimp crawfish
all kinds of
things that you might be used to seeing
down in louisiana oh i love it
all right let's move on over here
because this spot it just catches my eye
this is where you can find some snacks
yes
they've got uh mexican snacks or botanas
and some of it's ready to go in the
fridge so if you're in a hurry
but pretty much anything you see they
can whip up for you
and lastly here i see a stage which goes
along with the latin culture live music
right so we have fridays saturdays and
sundays
we've got entertainment on the stage uh
from 12 to four basically this is the
perfect time to come down with your
family especially during the holidays
absolutely all right well thank you so
much timo i love it here i'm gonna
eat my trails and go get to go boxing
for more information on el mercado call
702-735-7430 or visit el marcado
elvi.com